mm-hmm so I'll ask you very in general  Magnus because the whole world the whole  Chess World the whole world actually is  talking about cheating these days is in  general cheating a problem in chess do  you think  I think  um  individual people will answer the  question  um  pretty  um  you know differently depending on their  on their own  on their own experiences  um but um  um I mean regardless of whether it's  it's a massive problem or not  um it's um I think fairly uh fairly easy  to  um to to cheat and on General  you know  um  on a general basis I think that  um  um  cheaters in the in the Futures uh in the  future have to be um  you know it should not be taken uh  should not be taken lightly  um neither um online or over the board